hi guys I'm Greg with me is the lovely
and talented youtuber actress model
comedian Delilah that lava
Sawada from the lovely Jorge Jorge or
happy to talk for too long not for how
soft or does not know where else that I
did rent one of my few aspirations to
become superstar famous I go on Conan
O'Brien he is my hero I love that 8th
grade was 107 straight is when I
discovered him that's why I learnt
self-deprecating humor ok and that's
when I used to call him the cone zone
medication hey I used to feel better and
when I was at the press little middle
school kid oh that's so sweet
there's a video here conan visits
YouTube space in New York okay I'm I
figured we do YouTube yeah I love Conan
yes we love comedy alright so Conan I
love that I love your story thank you
that's really sweet
we are at Sadducees headquarters here in
Excelsior they're two very cool space
and this is Tom small I don't work there
not see how are you great
you had this VR Department is that
correct yeah I had a VR for the YouTube
space VR VR is virtual reality I don't
want to blow your mind with my high tech
talk
virtual reality is really the future I
think so I think it can help us in many
many ways but also I think we should go
carefully
yes that's like when you get married
yeah not in the future we'll get virtual
married haha works we have birthday how
come you're all worried about your show
and on our children ah yes part of this
business
this show pays for everything ah he
virtually says you know what's the name
conan anyway I never lie
I am very interested he annoys me
because of all my clothes my good into a
tube and then various lotions and gels
are injected between senses to put on my
body I have incredible erotic
experiences that take me to new heights
and then I get out of the queue or five
years later from the latest technology
involved I think just paper
Elian see what Weather Channel's figured
out over 40 years
haha there we go saddle that's funny
just fifty year old into I start with a
whole dressing okay since senator on
with your comment so you see the tool
pallet with the trash can easily got
doesn't Sophie time
why beer or Johnny Bravo
Johnny Bravo okay play with a hand they
just kill oh man
Wow people to put the marijuana industry
out of business we want to destroy the
point oh I just want condyloid okay okay
it's all gonna go for form you know
rubbing up against me when I see you
later
[Music]
welcome to an accuracy Billy Walker
pretty cool little red velvet donut no
it's good Wow nothing cigar was
virtually eor be cool
[Music]
this is actually how I behave at the
office I want to make a Xerox copy of
the stapler to the brain
I wonder if I film this only he can be
invertible in the future aren't you
doing a little friend attitude you're
for the VR right yeah this is
effectively for you if you have a
project here as this gluten-free but if
it isn't I'm gonna have virtual diarrhea
I don't think they'll take it like that
take a look wrong with that no you know
what my mother service for us in our
table we could go way to the station
so hit a bell and the Bell will only
appear if they're going to be happy with
it
also the way or doesn't like what I made
I'm just going to call the shots here
[Music]
[Music]
where you standing at me I should be
more pornographic that's the future is
good a fan possibly getting it on in
this kitchen
leave it boil oh my god oh my god you
have no answer I want to work anymore I
want to have some fun what's next let's
take another one oh my god fellas this
guy is a good trainer yeah my trainer
lissa Wayne Ian yeah
I'm just looking at him I miss
experiencing the sadness in his eyes
I don't know what they give to you in
the gulag so that's my apology
we goes picture there the yellow picture
oh yeah I can't fight this guy you
should be fighting back in the iron lung
wow you all that would be our Thursday
love it isn't a guy good to see ya
okay you're setting me out don't you
later storks I don't know if in a fight
with rich Mongolian ah and you could
definitely the dermatology
[Music]
melody gravel that's pretty cool yeah
here again you crazier than I knocked
out that champion I mean I'm on the test
so I just came here to see your face
register excitement enjoy very similar
guys like you in the audience nothing I
say get the chocolate ha ha I had a
German girlfriend and she likes to write
my special performance on a scale of 1
to 10 I try anal one night I thought I
was doing pretty well but she was
shouting nice not even know you just
thinking I can take it back to the
kitchen
this oil ah I can see you thinking about
if you think
[Music]
one take a bag
[Music]
Wow that was funny I was awesome
using this before no I've never seen
that that wouldn't be a reaction video
if either involve me I ain't no you
found the clip yeah well they get sent
to me by subscribers yes okay I will
submit and then I go hey okay let's do
it
that's awesome VR have you ever done VR
yes I did for the fine brothers I did
look I did not like it because I had to
do DS and I don't like be no first thing
that they had me do it's like hold on or
whatever like let go or something I
forgot what it was oh it's like real
life oh my gosh
I was not about that I was like I I will
act in horror movies I don't want to be
like actually in in one he was so funny
Conan - Larry I think Conan's one of the
best act like going with the act as if
like I am going being in the moment and
really working with whatever he's
getting yeah yeah and he can just bounce
off of anything that's one of the
reasons why I love him so much
oh well he was like khana giving the
hair everything he's the bad
wait is me based out of here yeah as an
LA no comment
oh yeah Rick uh in Enriquez or something
I think he's the casting director hire
us hire our could you please hire I have
to be in one of the skits for Conan oh
my god jagad in this video we be in one
of the sketches of Rick please please
please please hook it up
I want to write Conan a poem you look at
Helen like a romantic erotic oh maybe
you don't have a shocker because you are
the stalker maybe I'm an erotic yeah
like a romantic slowy erotic I would
take my time gonna start with I want to
be moaning and Conan moaning and Conan's
moaning and Conan I think you and I we
beat Bowman that is how you start the
lyric yeah I love you too get a mojo my
new girl nice Audrina I'm your
girlfriend right there
Shannon at Teresa Branson's videos
actually she acted in one of my videos
and she was very good every season
mind you looking duck your head it's a
little lower she's my new lover right
here I love you Jean her and I are gonna
go to the Americana tonight I'm gonna
take her to Olive Garden yeah my mom and
I used to work with her they used to
work together for two sets of twins well
only persons to LA and I to photograph
the twins this is like seven or eight
years ago and so we all should do both
knees together mom so I don't agree good
work for me I mean I don't know she's
gonna go on date just cuz she's married
and we don't fly like that but but I'll
see you she's got a guard get a chance
with a young hot ah ha ha ha ha ha ha I
mean AVI Akeno do you know something all
right guys subscribe to the real rejects
we're so off top of your saga the real
reaction okay c'mon O'Brien Huayra
subscribe to the real rejects subscribe
to my channel we're awesome we love you
yes subscribe to at all seriously check
out her channel you'll love it
you'll love this chance if Oliver on
Instagram following yeah I have way more
Instagram follower than her why does I
do it because I post much sexier bikini
photos than you do I mean I can't help
but that I figured out the algorithm and
Instagram YouTube still figuring it out
guys don't like me I like to my audience
retention it's like this I like it
thanks for saying hi I'm Sid Wilder just
goodly Oh